welcome to Advanced Agri gears today
we're diving into the top five
game-changing agricultural technologies
that are set to revolutionize farming in
2024 imagine drones monitoring your
crops 24 over 7 AI predicting the best
planting times and robotic Harvesters
working
tirelessly stay tuned as we reveal how
these Innovations are transforming
Agriculture and helping Farmers around
the world to maximize yield and
sustainability technology number one AI
powered crop monitoring artificial
intelligence is revolutionizing crop
monitoring by combining the power of
data with real-time analytics through
satellite imagery drones and ground
sensors farmers can receive instant
alerts about soil Health moisture levels
and potential pest
infestations imagine being able to
predict the perfect planting day or
identify areas of underperforming crops
without even stepping into the field
John a farmer in Iowa adopted a ey power
monitoring and saw a 20% increase in
yield these Technologies enabled him to
make data driven decisions such as
optimizing irrigation schedules and
applying targeted Pest Control measures
which reduced costs and maximized crop
output as we move into 2024 AI tools
will become more accessible helping
farmers of all sizes to boost efficiency
and sustainability ultimately leading to
smarter more resilient agricultural
practices technology number two
autonomous farming vehicles imagine a
fleet of tractors that can plow sew and
harvest without any human intervention
That's The Power of autonomous farming
vehicles these machines use Advanced GPS
machine learning and sensor technology
to navigate Fields with Precision day
and night in California a large-scale
farmer reported cutting his labor costs
by 30% in just one season by using
autonomous
Harvesters these vehicles are not only
more efficient but also help in
minimizing soil compaction by following
optimized paths plus they are safer
reducing the risk of accidents
associated with manual operations as we
head into 2024 more farmers are expected
to adopt autonomous vehicles ensuring
consistent farming operations even
amidst labor shortages the future is
here and it's self-driving technology
number three vertical farming systems
vertical farming is redefining how we
think about space in agriculture instead
of spreading out we're growing up by
using vertical Stacks Hydroponics and
LED lighting crops are grown indoors in
tightly controlled
environments this method significantly
reduces water usage up to 95% less than
traditional farming and virtually
eliminates the need for pesticides in
urban centers like Singapore where land
is scarce vertical Farms are producing
up to 200% more greens in just a
fraction of the space
these Farms can be set up in warehouses
shipping containers or even abandoned
buildings making it possible to grow
fresh produce closer to where people
live in 2024 expect to see vertical
farming become a key player in ensuring
food security especially in urban and
resource scarce
environments technology number four
smart irrigation systems water is a
precious resource and smart irrigation
systems are here to make every drop
count utilizing data from weather
forecasts soil moisture sensors and
real-time monitoring these systems
automatically adjust water delivery to
crops preventing both under and
overwatering for example smallscale
farmers in India who switched to smart
irrigation have reported up to a 50%
reduction in water usage while
maintaining or even increasing their
crop yields smart irrigation technology
not only conserves water but also
reduces energy costs and minimizes
nutrient runoff into local Water waste
as we move further into 2024 these
systems will become even more
sophisticated integrating AI to predict
optimal watering times ensuring maximum
growth while conserving our planet's
most vital
resource five technology number five
blockchain for supply chain transparency
blockchain is not just for
cryptocurrency it's transforming the
agricultural supply chain too by
providing a transparent immutable Ledger
of every transaction blockchain ensures
that all players from Farmers to
Distributors to Consumers have access to
the same verified data this level of
transparency helps prevent fraud reduce
food waste and build trust with
consumers who want to know exactly where
their food comes from for instance a
coffee producer in Colombia is using
blockchain to track beans from Farm to
cup ensuring quality and Fair Trade
Practices as we look towards 2024
blockchain will play a critical role in
making Supply chains more transparent
efficient and trustworthy enhancing
sustainability and consumer confidence
in the global Food Market which of these
Technologies do you think will have the
biggest impact on farming in
2024 let us know in the comments below
your insights could be featured in our
next video don't forget to subscribe to
Advanced Agri gears for more insights
into the future of farming and check out
our next video on sustainable farming
practices that are changing the world
right now